- Wow.
- Oh my gosh.
Say hi to Brooke if y'all ever met.
- I've never met...
- Hello.
- It's such a pleasure
to be here with you-
- Thank you.
- honestly.
Yeah.
- I'm a fan.
- Legend over here.
(Brooke laughs)
- So, you got your start
in theater in Improv,
here in LA.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Did you love it right away?
- Instantly, I loved it.
I was in his class at iOS
and I was doing a space scene,
and he was like, "That's good."
I was like, "Wait, this is good?" (laughs)
And so, I just fell head
over heels with Improv,
started going to theater
five times a week.
Just became obsessed.
- I love that.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- That kind of passion.
- Yeah.
- So now,
you're like a big Broadway fan,
which I am as well.
(Echo chuckles)
So how many shows did you go to last year?
I hear you go to more shows than anybody.
- I mean, I saw about 40 shows last year.
- Ooh.
- I love it.
Look at all those playbills.
- Look at that.
(audience applauding)
- Yeah. Yeah.
- This is called supporting the arts.
- Oh.
- That's what I call this photo. (laughs)
- Definitely.
- That is so cool.
- And there was a lot
of rush tickets there.
I wasn't just like making it
rain on Broadway, you know?
So I was being
(Kelly laughing)
economical with it.
Rush your tickets if you can.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
- So Brooke,
you've been on Broadway a few times.
So do you have a favorite
moment of your own?
- I was going into Chicago,
and Ann Reinking came to, sort of,
the dance kind of...
I was just working with the choreographer
to sort of see if I could do...
if Fosse could work on my body.
And she did the whole final dance duet
with me in the mirror.
- Wow.
- And I thought I had died
and just gone to heaven.
And she came down in the
elevator with me and she said,
"You will be a great
addition to this company."
And I was like, (whimpers).
- That's so nice.
It's so special.
- It was so beautiful-
- Yeah.
- and it was...
Yeah, it was pretty amazing, so...
- I love special moments like that.
Well, congratulations on
season two of Grand Crew.
- Thank you.
- That's incredible.
So what's happening this season
other than some hoe on a phone? (laughs)
- I mean, yeah,
there's some phone hoeing,
(laughs) but there's...
I mean, honestly, we're having
so much fun this season.
Before the season started,
Phil had one phrase,
he said, "Winefeld," so it's
gonna be a lot more wine.
A lot more situational comedy,
and just, you know, a lot of
fun and warmth there, so...
- Such a great cast.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
The chemistry is cool.
- I feel so unfortunate.
We all were friends before
we started the show.
- [Kelly] That's why I love that.
I remember-
- It's based off of-
- first talking to you about this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
It's based off our actual friend group.
We're all like UCB-trained comedians.
And so we would meet
at this wine bar weekly
and just have wine and unpack
life, love, relationships and-
- And you're like-
- Phil-
- "This should be a show."
- It should be a show.
(all laughing)
And Phil wrote about it,
and so we feel so
fortunate to get to do it.
- It's so cool.
Yeah, to make something
happen with your friends.
- Yeah.
- Like what a-
- So rare.
- great line, yeah.
- And laughter.
- I mean, my God-
- Yeah.
- That's medicine.
- it's just medicine.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Echo] That's medicine.
- Your character is back
on the dating scene.
- Yes.
- So trying to pick up women.
So do you ever use pickup
lines in real life?
- (laughs) I mean, I try to...
You know, I would like,
"Hey, can I get you a drink?"
Or just something like that.
- But that's like a good look.
- That's a good...
- Yeah.
- But one pickup line
that I did love, like
always, it's very dumb but,
"Did it hurt when you
fell from heaven?"
- No. No. (claps)
(all laughing)
- I would never use it.
I would never use it.
But objectively, I'm like,
"That's not horrible."
- It's so...
Wait, actually, that's a great way in,
because it's so bad-
- [Echo] It's so bad.
- the girl would probably be like-
- I got that line.
"Okay man, come on."
- You got that?
Oh my God.
- It was something like,
"Did you hit your head when
you fell from the sky?"
Like, it was like something like that.
And I was like, "Seriously?"
- I'm like a-
- I don't know
if it's so corny, I'm
almost wanted to be like-
- See?
- "All right. Okay."
- See? I almost start
up with like a dad joke,
like a bad dad joke.
- That's funny.
- Like, Do you wanna hear a pizza joke?
- Okay.
- Oh, nevermind.
It's too cheesy.
(all laughing)
- There was one that we
were talking backstage,
like a little 12-year-old
boy goes up to girls like,
"Do you like peanuts?"
She goes, "Yeah."
"Do you like cashews?"
He goes, "How about a date?"
- Oh my gosh that's cute.
- Oh.
- Isn't that cute?
- That is low-key better... (laughing)
- That was better than
yours, man. (laughs)
- Oh, yeah.
No, but in real life, I would never...
I gotta put this prerequisite out.
I would never use the pickup line.
- He's like, "Wait.
I don't want my social life
to die right here."
- No, please.
- That's like, girls calling
in like, "That is not true?"
(all laughing)
No, I definitely wouldn't.
- Oh my gosh. All right,
let's do another break.
Everybody, watch Grand
Crew, Fridays, on NBC.